hi welcome back to our series on
qualitative research methods this module
explores a major qualitative study
design in depth interviews just remind
us an overview of the modules our goal
is to enhance our capacity to
conceptualize design and conduct
qualitative research in the health
sciences through six modules in the
series the first is what is qualitative
research the second focus is on
developing an effective qualitative
research question the third and fourth
address major qualitative study designs
interviews and focus groups the fifth
module is an overview of the qualitative
data analysis principles and practices
and the last addresses scientific rigor
and qualitative research this module
examines in-depth interviews as a tool
in qualitative study design so there are
a number of qualitative study designs
from various traditions approaches
include in-depth interviews the purpose
of them is to explore individual
experiences and perceptions in rich
detail the second major approach is
focus groups these generate unique
insights into shared experiences in
social norms through group discussion
will address those in the next module
observations can be participant
observations or non participant
observations where we're learning about
behaviors and interactions in natural
settings we're studying the cultural
aspects of a setting or a particular
context and the last major qualitative
study design is document review this is
the purpose of these studies in this
method is to identify patterns of
communication describing characteristics
of organizations or processes based on
in-depth and systematic review of
documents related to the program or
policy of interest
this module will examine in depth
interviews I like this phrase by Lofland
I think it characterizes really the
essence of what an in-depth interview is
that is a guided conversation so this
image helps us understand
and then in an in-depth interview we may
not always know the path that the
interview is going to take and in fact
that's a strength of the method at the
same time as the interviewer we need to
keep offense or some jersey barriers
along the edge of the interview so that
the respondent doesn't veer off in a
direction that's really too tangential
there are a number of ways in which
in-depth interviews can illuminate
various focal topics and so we can think
about using them again when we're
interested in understanding individual
perspectives and experiences when we're
addressing sensitive topics it may be
that our question of interest has some
particular stigma to it or for some
reason may be sensitive and we may find
that the intimacy and trust and rapport
that can be established in an in-depth
interview as an asset in addressing a
sensitive topic we can also use in-depth
interviews when there are concerns about
fear of reprisal so for instance our
team has done work in looking at
different innovative models of care for
frail older adults who are on Medicaid
than getting their services through a
Medicaid program and you might imagine
that speaking I say in a focus group
setting might might be anxiety provoking
for the clients and those individuals
receiving those services and so the
again privacy of an in-depth interview
might help address concerns about fear
of reprisal and we can think about
interviews of course when structured
survey approaches don't work when the
topic that we're interested in doesn't
lend itself nicely to checkboxes and
force choice options on a survey
instrument so let's talk a little bit
about sampling for interviews the aim in
its sampling design for an interview
study is to identify key informants key
informants is a term that refers to
individuals who have knowledge of or
experience with the phenomenon of
interest and they're willing to speak
about it the goal in the sampling
approach is breath attaining a bra
odd range of perspectives a hole across
a spectrum it's not representativeness
so we're not concerned with taking a
random sample you know every fifth
person on administrative claims list the
size the sample size varies depending on
the complexity of the inquiry and it
can't be decided in advance the sample
size in qualitative studies and an
in-depth interviews in in particular is
determined by the principle of
theoretical saturation the theoretical
saturation is the point at which no new
concepts emerge from the data and so as
we're collecting data we're hearing no
new ideas that emerge from from that
conversation and then we know that the
sample is complete so it is not possible
to identify a sample size in advance a
few minutes on data collection what does
an interview guide look like we think of
an interview guide as a framework for
the interviewer it's not a structured
script each tin tablet that must be
followed in a standard way every time
but rather a framework for the
interviewer to use in facilitating the
conversation interview guides contain a
list of main questions and then probes
so specific probes that help the
individual understand the intent of the
question questions are open and
non-directive this harkens back to the
principle of qualitative methods being
exploratory in nature non directional
the interviewer may diverge to pursue an
emergent idea in detail so if we think
of that path through the marsh the
interview is encouraged to diverge or
move away from the interview guide in
order to follow a lead that the
respondent may offer up his or her
comments the interviewer may reword
questions drop or add questions and
change the sequence of questions so for
those of us who are quantitatively
oriented or trained this may feel a bit
uncomfortable it's very different than a
structured standard
survey instrument in which innovator
Reliability must be computed and
individual interviewers must be trained
in order to administer the survey in the
same way every time this is really a
much more organic process so let's look
at an example from the literature this
is a study our team here at Yale did
looking at top performing hospitals in
care of patients who have heart attacks
and we were interested in understanding
what the most successful hospitals were
doing in order to have better outcomes
in their care for patients with heart
attacks and so the design was to include
high performing hospitals and low
performing hospitals hospitals that did
well and not so well on their outcomes
for patients with heart attacks and to
go to those hospitals and have in-depth
interviews with the key informants at
each Hospital the key informants you
remember are people who are close to the
phenomenon of interest so in this
instance it was the key staff in these
hospitals who were most directly
involved in the care of patients with
heart attacks so we'll look at the
interview guide from this study so this
is the first question and there's a
series of questions and we'll review the
question itself and then reflect a bit
on the purpose of each question so this
is the opening question to the interview
guide you can see very broad let's start
by having you describe what you do here
the purpose of this question is to
provide a comfortable non-threatening
way into the interview we also can
locate the person in the organization
from his or her own perspective they're
describing to you what what they do
within that organization and we can also
gain a sense of their role in the larger
process of providing care to patients
with a mi so it's a really very helpful
opening question to both set the stage
and to give the interviewer some sense
of the respondent so second question
what happens to a patient with a MI who
comes here can you walk me through that
process the purpose of this question is
to elicit a description of the hospital
processes for a mi care so we're
starting to get to the
specific area of interest we want to
know what's happening within that
hospital within the hospital walls as
they're caring for patients with AMI and
so they'll begin to describe that
process to us this question also gives
the interviewer the opportunity to
explore a broad range of factors that
the interviewee considers relevant to
ami patient care in this setting meaning
we're turning it over to the respondent
you know what happens to the patient and
can you walk me through that process as
they're describing elements of the
process the interviewer then has the
opportunity to explore to listen
carefully and diverge or explore a
specific comment or reflection offered
by the respondent third question in this
guide have there been efforts to improve
the care of patients with ami here again
very broad and open the purpose of this
question is to explore the hospital
quality improvement efforts broadly
conceived right so this doesn't script
the individual and encourage the
individual respondent to talk only about
formal quality improvement initiatives
for instance but rather wide open door
there might be follow-up probes that we
could ask as the respondent starts
speaking we might want to know well what
got that started how does the
organization recognize problems or
opportunities can you describe things
that needed a ironing out along the way
these kinds of probes can be used to
encourage the respondent to keep
following a path of commentary the next
question it focuses on post-hospital
discharge and the question again very
broad now let's hear about what happens
to the patient after they leave the
hospital who do they see and how does
that work again you see how open this is
here we're encouraging respondents to
talk about all aspects of discharge for
AMI patients so what happens to them
when they leave the hospital the things
that happen within the hospital and in
various post discharge settings here
this last question has the process
always worked this way and if it's
changed can you tell me about when that
happened and how it went the purpose of
this question is trying to get a sense
for the dynamics within that
in the institution how well change is
received and initiated and what kinds of
things they do within the organization
in terms of processes for implementing
improvements there so let's review
together some basic types of probes that
the interviewer can use during the
conversation in order to elicit more
information or to get clarification from
the respondent then there are a range of
these techniques available to
interviewers from being silent being
quiet and nodding slowly and listening
and just encouraging through to asking
various kinds of questions clarification
questions now you said the word X can
you describe what you meant by that and
these probes should be used at the
discretion of the interviewer in order
to generate richer detail from the
respondent as it's appropriate so
conducting interview what is it like
when you get out in the field you've got
your interview guide and you're ready to
begin collecting data so beginning the
interview good rapport is imperative
clearly you're sitting in a one-on-one
interaction you're going to be asking
the respondent about a topic that likely
has great meaning for him or her and
you're there as the researcher
establishing rapport happens in the very
first few moments of an interaction and
so attention to rapport is really
imperative participants will only talk
candidly if they feel comfortable in the
space where they are if they trust the
interviewer they feel that the
interviewer is from a legitimate
organization that they're genuinely
interested in what the respondent has to
say they'll predict provide
confidentiality and that the interviewer
is there really to listen to them and
not to judge them so careful attention
to all of these dynamics in the very
first seconds of the interaction is
really really very important without
good rapport or with some tension in the
in the dynamic or some discomfort on
part of the interviewer it's not likely
that they'll in fact share the degree of
formation that you know you're hoping
for so I want to review play some audio
tape to give you an illustration of what
a live interviewer interview sounds like
and this is an excerpt from an interview
the very beginning the opening of an
interview where the interviewer is
introducing the study and its goals to
the respondent so let's listen I'm here
today basically to try to meet a lot of
people to talk about the kind of care
that's provided for my patients and
we're coming because we're trying to
understand the differences between
places that achieve different levels of
performance right and I'm really glad
I'm meeting with you because actually
interventional pebbel would have a
pretty good idea what the reality is I
want to tell you that the way we're
organized is I'm recording because it
keeps me so I can actually talk to you
instead of having to take notes we
transcribe these we then go through them
and try to bring out themes and what we
can learn from what's going on we don't
ever identify the person who said things
and even to the point that we don't
identify the site if we ever use it we
mostly use the information to help put
together a picture about what's going on
but I want to assure you that your name
will never be associated with you know
this and we do this because we want
people to be candid it's important for
people to be honest otherwise we're not
going to learn anything like and you can
imagine I was talking to you know chair
of Medicine he wants to know that if he
says anything candidly that it's not
going to be linked and so you know we
take very seriously our responsibility
to to protect the identities and so
forth of the people okay so what did you
hear there there are a number of things
that the interviewer was doing in those
very first moments of the interaction in
order to encourage the respondent to
feel comfortable in the space to be
clear about why the participant was
chosen and to describe the procedures
and the privacy issues related to
related to the study so let's listen to
one more excerpt from an interview in
this exchange you'll hear three voices
there's the respondent there's a pride
marry interviewer and there's a
secondary interviewer a male voice who's
being trained to do qualitative data
collection he's a cardiologist who was
on our team and had not done qualitative
interviewing before and so we paired him
with a senior researcher on our team and
so you'll hear the dialogue between the
three of them so let's listen um we have
actually pluses and minuses I mean if
you go first to this bus protocol to the
am i keeping within 90 minutes has been
quite a challenge I mean how you have
the same protocol at your institution
how are you doing ah he's wearing his
researcher hat today but even so I'm
just giving our cousin I will old mother
the negatives as well not to take too
much time we can maybe talk offline on
an email but we're doing very well
so what did you hear in that exchange a
few things were going on you heard of
the respondent answering a question but
first initiating a question to the
interviewer how are things going at your
institution and you hear the senior
researcher interrupting to say he's
wearing his researcher hat today this
redirecting is really very critical in
our work we often have research
interviewers out in the field who also
have clinical expertise and so they may
have a clinical hat or an administrator
hat as well as the researcher hat and in
the context of the interview it's very
important to sort of have your
researcher lands on and to be sure that
the respondent sees you in that way
the second thing that happened in that
exchange was the male interviewer offers
to answer the questions later this is
really very important when a respondent
asks a question and you don't want to be
perceived as being evasive or or
non-responsive and so offering to
address questions after the interview
lets the respondent know that you're you
know you're willing to to be candid and
have that exchange but later in the in
the conversation and then focusing at
the topic at hand saying you know we're
mindful of your time we've got limited
time here this shows respect for the
interviewer and also puts bounds around
the interview so in that brief exchange
they accomplished a few different things
so several things we want to avoid when
we're doing qualitative data collection
through interview techniques the first
is influencing respondents by asking
leading questions or conveying one's own
view this seems obvious maybe and very
straightforward it's much more difficult
in practice because we may have leading
questions or convey our view implicitly
or explicitly through our interactions
with a respondent and so we want always
to be thinking about you know very broad
wide open non-judgmental kinds of
questions and encouraging the respondent
to both you have positive and negative
sorts of statements since
we want to hear all of the things that
are going well we also want to hear some
of the things that are not going so well
so inviting the respondent to provide a
balanced view moving too quickly from
one topic to the next this is very
tricky and the only way to really master
a sensitivity to this is just to do
interviews but the interviewer is in a
tricky spot where you want to leave
enough time for the respondent to
express fully their thoughts sometimes
people need to pause a moment and so you
don't want to truncate a line of
commentary prematurely at the same time
you don't want them to sort of linger
too long and so the tendency may be for
the interviewer to simply jump to the
next topic and we want to be mindful of
that potential lost opportunities don't
want to interrupt the informant here
sometimes we do in our own excitement
maybe speak over or ask a probing
question or come right back on top of a
comment because we're in the momentum of
the interview and we're starting to get
excited so we need to exercise some
restraint not to interrupt their
informant tips for a good interview
there were some things that you can do
that will ensure a positive interaction
and yield a very rich narrative data
first knowing your interview guide and
the potential probes well this is really
very critical and the interview guides
this is one reason there it's useful if
there's simply five to seven broad
questions after doing a couple of
interviews those will be embedded in
your mind it's not very good for an
interaction if the interviewer is
looking down reading their paper sort of
stumbling or feeling forced really
critical part of this is knowing the the
informed consent statements that you're
very comfortable and casual in your
communication of the introduction the
purpose of the study and confidentiality
assurances so that the interview feels
like a comfortable interaction from the
beginning rehearse that introduction
beware of power differentials in the
room this happens when we send you know
large teams of people with various
credentials background expertise to the
field there are always power
differentials that underlie these
dynamics and being aware of those
sensitive that if those can be really
very important to creating a safe space
for open dialogue put on your
qualitative researcher hat so again
don't bring the kind of clinical
knowledge or programmatic knowledge or
policy knowledge to the table but rather
your open inquisitive non-judgmental
researcher hat and be sure that the
respondent perceives you in that role
speaking judiciously so being careful
with those probes while it's helpful to
have those potential probes content
probes or the stylistic probes we
reviewed briefly it's important to speak
judiciously not to use those very very
freely because that has the strong
potential to lead the respondent in a
specific direction and then lastly be
comfortable with silence and so pause
listen let the respondent compose
themselves bring their thoughts to order
and then speak again and so in being
comfortable with silence the seven
second pause is something that you know
I think all of us struggle with I know
that I do but it's very important in an
interview dynamic so thank you for your
attention